what is that on your chest
no it's not what you're thinking it is a
t-shirt though oh i love your t-shirt
where did you get it i got it at the big
mood store.com oh it's really nice i
love how you just care so much about
your own chest but not mine because you
know i have something special here too
the we have the bigger design yes
whether you like large graphics or small
graphics we have a merch for you so go
check it out it says uh no matter what
phase you're always whole yeah because
you are like the moon
you know maybe you can't always see it
but it's always there yeah so your whole
you can get yours today at
bigmoodstore.com just in time for
halloween too for this yes pretty yellow
moon it's perfect for halloween go get
it
i love you
say it back
[Music]
good morning
oh yeah this is coming out in the
morning good morning guys
it's us the big mood girls yay yay
to another episode of big mood i am gina
i'm jess i'm nikki tiff here and we have
another fun episode where we're going to
be talking about our life updates
because we always do so much [ __ ] since
our in between our life updates we
always have so much [ __ ] going on we
think that you guys like to hear these
so it breaks up the the monotony of like
we just do like relationship topics yeah
don't you like you want to know what's
going on
right she's clearly struggling with the
baby that's getting bigger right now i
wanted to cross my legs [ __ ] i can't and
every time she makes a movement she's
like it takes her all her breath it
really does you're breathing for two
it's okay um yeah so now i'm 19 weeks so
like it's not i mean which means five
months by the way but i'm not like that
big yet but it definitely is like taking
a lot of energy out of it you only have
four months left i know i'm almost done
this is crazy yeah you just we just you
just told us like two days ago yeah you
just had sex
casey inseminated me you know like
that's weird
right now that's the pregnancy
that's very technical
yeah so at 20 the 20-week mark is
exactly halfway and that's next week for
me oh [ __ ] yeah you can do a half half
um
trimester part of the race
trimester yeah but then i guess it would
be a bi-master semester
that's right that's right
that
where
be yeah i didn't pay attention it's cool
mid-year sale or something
my annual mid-year sale
i don't know it's weird that's crazy i
know it's so fast i think it's so funny
how like people refer to their pregnancy
and
infants like oh it's like
12 weeks long amount of weeks imagine if
we did that 154 weeks old yeah
you know why though that like for so
with isaac i didn't know what the reason
three years old
did you do the math because i needed
that
i really didn't yeah i had no idea how
many weeks are you ready
i thought i nailed it
all right how about like 1062 weeks old
i
[Laughter]
yeah i never knew the reason why they
went by weeks with pregnancy and then
why they went by months for babies i'm
like i was so [ __ ] annoyed i mean
they grow so rapidly between the weeks
like it means a lot
one is like a different milestone and
there's there's like and also for the
weeks part so then they say we're
pregnant for nine months right but if
you count it it's 40 weeks so you're
like wait there's like four weeks and
every month isn't it 10 months being
pregnant but because some months don't
have
like the full like 30 days or whatever
or i forgot the exact explanation it's
like five days i guess over the span of
so that's almost like a week yeah
exactly it ends up breaking down a
little bit different to make it to nine
months babies grow so fast and they
always grow out of their clothing so
fast yeah like it's such a waste of
money right getting clothes for them so
i want to keep my baby in a burlap sack
until he's like
one two or something that's why you make
friends with people having babies around
the same time or like they're a little
bit older you get their hand-me-downs
yes and they already got hand-me-downs
from some other person's handwriting
this baby already got a hand me down see
a crib oh yeah our neighbors gave us
their crib i i always think it's so
funny when people buy designer baby
clothes yeah come on
baby clothes cost a lot more in designer
brands yeah i bet they're milking like
they're actual adult designer clothes
because they're like those they got the
money to spend they're just gonna waste
their money on this yeah let's charge
them with the [ __ ] because they'll
spend whatever right because they don't
want to buy the knock-off those are the
type of people that won't buy the
knockout that's true but you get a
cricket printer okay yeah
yeah no you can make it vinyl like it
looks like legit like you'll see those
tick tocks where they're making like
knock off
nikes yeah no i didn't know that yeah
that cricket printer yeah wow because
they do vinyl well you know i don't buy
fake [ __ ] so no i'm just kidding how
would you know
yeah i want to have fake
designer baby clothes
from china i'll make them for you out of
paper wait so are you going to have a
baby i'm like really confused she just
wants to be able to do the to to do the
i know sometimes i want a baby
right sometimes like most of the time i
don't it's like okay you know what the
only th if i unless something changes i
kind of want a baby but under very
strict rules like my conditions like it
has to be a surrogate because i don't
want to do the whole birthing process
that scares the crap out of me and like
my baby has to be cool if he's not cool
i'm just like all right get up gina
if i have to interview your baby
twins i'll give you one oh thanks yeah
so we'll be like that's so crazy they
look so similar
like you guys just look so sneaky oh my
god they're gonna be if you went through
a pregnancy with twins you're gonna be
like [ __ ] that i worked for that kid
but then it's gonna start all these
rumors like oh gina's kid looks like
steve
weird we knew steve was [ __ ] all the
girls
we could have a whole internet drama
where i'm like no no yeah no he would
never never it looks nothing like and
like we'll like subtly like stab each
other
and everyone's like i think they're in
like i think there's drama yeah like no
hey guys uh my kid grew up and he has
blue eyes for some reason but it's like
totally not steve's baby okay like you
and sieber in a picture together i'm
like yeah the picture why are you
standing next to him
so yeah i'm like i'm the same where i'm
like sometimes i want i want a
five-year-old that's what i want yeah
that's how hard it is oh my god
everyone's eight years old
why not skip why no okay so everyone
always wants to skip the newborn stage
yeah yeah and that's the [ __ ] easiest
stage minus the sleep deprivation yeah
but they don't smell like [ __ ] they
squirt that they're [ __ ] easy they
don't talk back to you all you have to
do is change their diapers they cry
i can't shut it up i can see my second
alarm yeah
figure it out you just gotta make sure
that they're not hurt that they're
burped that they're clean like they're
diaper streams that they're comfortable
i can barely clean myself though you
know my eight-year-old won't talk back
to me if i smack them you know
absolutely
we'll figure it out somehow yeah that's
why like for me out of isaac's entire
life i think my
i mean right every stage is like my new
favorite because even right now like
he's a [ __ ]
little [ __ ]
but i would i would still kind of like
no maybe not okay i don't know wipe his
ass no no i was gonna say i would still
maybe pick this stage over his previous
stage but i really [ __ ] loved his
previous stage because he was still so
like sweet
like hormones i don't know him now i
haven't spent as much time with him now
but like at eight i was like oh i could
i could do that yeah i think for me it's
like between
400 400 weeks yeah 400 years so it's
like before they realize that they
like could potentially have power over
you at some point it's like they're
still innocent enough to like that
you're the parent so they like kind of
believe everything you say and they like
yeah listen to everything you say and
then so kind of specifically he kind of
had like a phase where
like between
like
six to about
nine ish or eight he was like a pre-teen
like that was his pre-teen and then from
10 to like
yeah like 12 that i think was my most
favorite because he wasn't
he wasn't that like there was no
attitude like he wasn't as like entitled
or whatever
like kind of behavior that he had back
then and then kind of now
that little like sweet spot was i think
is probably my most favorite yeah
because he was super independent yeah
really like loving and responsible i
think that's going to come back around
again like after 25 yeah so like once
they're and so yeah you just got to get
through the trenches of the teenagers
yeah it just started and then you're
having another one jesus no but then
also like you know being pregnant and
all their hormones and [ __ ] like we're
always like there's two very hormonal
people in the home right now for casey
dude oh my god he's been a saint he has
been a saint
drinking a lot now or no
not drinking anything nothing
because of therapy though like our
household has been like
okay cool we have a peacemaker here
because he like learned how to
communicate a lot better and like can
control his his own anger his own ego
and all that stuff and i'm like okay
cool let's all follow his example
because isaac and i are [ __ ] wild
right now yeah i like isaac when how old
was he when we went to japan seven oh he
was this yeah
he was seven i remember i remember that
time i'm like
i know that you guys were having issues
with him but then like because we
weren't his parents he would just always
behave with your problems
you know like oh i guess i'm just a
nancy i can't be an uncle but
you can be nowadays
we have so many nieces and nephews that
i'm like i kind of love that because
they [ __ ] love yes like when we come
over it's like the [ __ ] time of the
we're celebrities
yeah more than like my actual kid's not
going to give a [ __ ] no i'm like do you
know how cool i am yeah and you can just
like do things with the kids without
consequences like give them a drum set
i don't have to deal with that right
you guys do give it to parents that you
don't like that much yeah yeah give them
legos
and one of those at night so many noisy
kid toys too
i go to uh my sister-in-law's house and
i'm like i can't handle all the noisy
kid toys my mom took the batteries out
of all of them yeah my mom is straight
up ended in engagement once because her
her dudes kids were too loud in the
morning she's like yeah
i'm not gonna do that i'm like all right
there was maybe some other steps you
could have taken but you do you i guess
yeah duct tape's a thing yeah right
benadryl just
like an ear earplug yeah but you know
she's insane so who knows that's funny
what's new in your life nikki
a lot oh i cut 10 inches off my hair i
know it looks like yeah i don't like it
i don't want her to keep cutting her
hair [ __ ]
it grows so i grow an inch i know that's
why i'm like why do you keep cutting it
because it's heavy how long how long was
it before it was down to here that's ten
inches yeah
girl
have you never sent it
so that's ten inches
remember last last shoot you were like
it looks like you have a bob when one of
my
ears so i was like cute i'm just gonna
cut it to that layer oh you took it and
ran with it yeah it's like i ran i like
it i just kind of feel like you know
they say like your hair holds memories
of whatever time it was going through i
just wanted to cut all 20 20 off yeah i
was just like that's 20 20 is about here
yeah you're gone i actually been
thinking about doing the same no stop
cutting your hair off listen jess i'm
vote not cutting hair off just like your
hair is short that's why i'm like don't
[ __ ]
like while we're young and we have
luscious hair when you get old you're
going to be doing these old [ __ ] lady
haircuts keep your nice youthful hair
while you're still doing it you have a
filipina you're bound to have the
filipino hair bob oh that's true yeah i
can't wait listen i was like once i
start getting grays i can finally start
dyeing my hair because i've been putting
it off because every time i go to the
hair salon my lady's like you have such
rich color in your hair like don't do it
yeah that's really good people painting
their hair that color yeah like you
you're gonna lose it and it's gonna
damage your hair blah blah so i'm like
okay once i start going great then i'll
be able to do it i found five gray hairs
she dies at five strands
look i can do it
my hairdresser was still like no don't
do it good for her it's your head of
hair no but she doesn't need to break it
i'm not right so i'm like very scared
like grow out especially because your
hair grows so fast you can [ __ ] it up
and just like all this blonde [ __ ] right
here this is my dyed hair from when i
had blue hair
but everything else is virgin hair like
i haven't done anything with this hair
so yeah see it grows fast i'm really
thinking of going back to like semi
darkish hair oh this is expensive okay
yeah that's the other thing one is
expensive good blonde i love blonde you
are never even though do your head of
hair you're never allowed to go back to
brunette yeah never
ever yeah you have to stay blonde you
just please
i'll do it yeah i mean i see like um
what's her name uh there's like some
actresses that like have been blonde for
so long and then when they go back to
brown i'm like oh that really made a
difference yeah yeah that's amelia
a lot of people that are
pale they are they think going dark will
make them look more tan but it actually
makes them look more pale yeah yeah
exactly so i think it's harsh i think
that my face and my skin are pretty
harsh with the dark hair like i look
like a russian [ __ ]
the blonde kind of makes me honestly you
look like a politician when i first met
you i was a politician yeah you had your
dark hair and you wore it like you
didn't really style it you just always
like wore it back and you had like very
conservative clothes like you would you
know you still do
like a congresswoman yeah the way she
speaks is very neutral and so i'm like
she's a [ __ ] politician she never
points it you should like this yeah
especially when she gets heated about
certain topics and i'm like oh my god i
don't want to [ __ ] with her i'll vote
for you [ __ ] just like stop yelling at
him
for you jesus christ maybe i should run
for office he should you complain about
enough stuff just change it it's
convincing i'm really good at getting
[ __ ] done yeah exactly oh my god you
scared the [ __ ] out of this company we
were working with yeah yeah yeah we
almost had to sue someone but like my
very carefully crafted emails uh avoided
that because they went ahead and didn't
oh yeah yeah politicians she should
whatever it is man build the wall [ __ ]
it i'll vote for you yeah
just kidding i'll hire you for whenever
i need someone i'm just gonna hire you
as a professional arguer yeah i don't
know what that is you missed my title
yeah yeah i'll give you a sick title
like a cfo litigator yeah there you go
i would love to see just like do an
exercise where we all are we have the
same topic we're trying to sue one
person for a certain thing and each of
us has to write an email and see how
different it is oh yeah that'll be
awesome exercise mine will be like one
sentence it's just that's why i want to
pay off [ __ ] i wanted to do an
episode tell us what you think about
this of like us all doing a powerpoint
presentation on whatever subject we want
oh yeah like whatever subjects
it does sound funny
yeah well tips like i don't want to do
that i like that one better you must
just argue or like craft an
email it's really clicky the clicky
thing is fun
experience you [ __ ] i barely but i want
it to be like the most random topics
like mine will be yeah why pregnancy is
the work of the devil exactly you know
i'll just send this so
yeah because part of it is not knowing
what people's topics are going to be
it's so random and it's something that
you got to be passionate about it you
know what how do they present it that
doesn't matter
though because i'm i'm insecure i need
to know we'll we'll yeah we'll give you
go first we'll give you help yeah you
don't have to raw doctor
because i'm like yeah i guess i am like
i have to realize like
i am oh yeah like what does it look like
it's mainly like being pissed off that's
when i can really okay really get it
pick a topic you're pissed off about it
that's what i could not kill
how to convince people i was not born
and raised you can do a powerpoint
presentation on that how everything
needs to be symmetrical yeah
i was definitely not born in tijuana
she will never believe that you spent
the majority of your life in the united
states
i [ __ ] love that we should do that
just get [ __ ] and then just do it yeah
yeah yeah we have to be dragged it'll be
the last episode of she's gonna have one
glass of wine oh my god that's yeah
don't get me drunk
i would love to also be drunk can we
wait till i'm done breastfeeding yeah
she's well you'll be waiting until next
year she'll be brain drunk because she's
oh true you can pretend to be drunk when
everyone else is drunk you know that you
can yeah i can you can do that i can i
can actually remember you can embody
feels like to be drunk or to be on other
substances and like my body remembers so
then i end up having like a what is it
like a deja vu kind of feeling but like
i can like make my body feel that way
right so i can give you a non-alcoholic
beer and then you'll feel like you'll be
put back in that place fun fact tiff and
i have actually been so drunk that we
both puked on the side of a freeway once
yes
yes
there's an instagram story on it yeah
oh yeah somewhere in someone's archive
yeah and someone's archived it's in
there god damn it
that was a fun night it was but uh what
we ended up puking up was that that
dinner that we had that night
[Laughter]
and it was really delicious and uh we
ordered it from door dad oh
so god connects you with the restaurants
you love right now and right to your
door and now you can get the grocery
essentials you need with doordash too
you can get drinks snacks and other
household items delivered in under an
hour so once this baby comes through
getting oh yeah diapers or oh yeah or i
don't know formula for some reason or
whatever other baby essentials i need in
the middle of the night that will be
done
you know what i love like when i order
from a restaurant on doordash though
like well at least in los angeles
they'll give you the option that you
have like 10 minutes you can also get
something from 7-eleven
for like the without any extra price so
then i'm like oh yeah i wanted freaking
donuts too oh my god just add it on to
my order yeah that's so convenient and
ordering is super easy you open the
doordash app you choose what you want
from where you want and your items will
be left safely outside your door with
the contactless delivery drop off
setting with over three hundred thousand
partners in the us puerto rico canada
and australia you can support your
neighborhood go-to's or choose from your
favorite national restaurants like
popeyes chipotle and cheesecake factory
among others so for a limited time our
listeners can get 25 off and zero
delivery fees on their first order of
fifteen dollars or more when you
download the doordash app and enter code
mood that's 25
off up to a 10 value
and zero delivery fees on your first
order when you download the doordash app
in the app store and enter code mood
don't forget that's code mood for 25 off
your first order with doordash subject
to change terms apply
yes
and if you don't want to be in
just let the silence be there
[Laughter]
you have to fill the silence
she goes yes
i love when just loses it it's the
greatest
when she tries to speak as she's
laughing
uh if you don't want to be in tiff's
position pregnant
um we have the pill club if you're on
birth control remember to take your
pills is already enough work if i had to
remember that's why i had an implant but
if i had to remember to take pills i
would be so pregnant all the time yeah i
did i would always forget
um but now you can forget go into the
doctor in person to get your
prescription and pick it up from the
pharmacy the pill club wants to help
take the work out of taking care of
yourself the pill club is a birth
control subscription prescribed by a
medical professional and delivered
straight to your door for free which i
wish we had back then yeah because going
to the clinic sucks yeah it was really
embarrassing when you're like 18 19 20
yeah and you wait there for like five
hours at a time yeah
and they're like do you want to disguise
who's calling so that your parents don't
know like yes god i wish we had this
back then
uh the pill club carries over 120 fda
approved brands most brands of birth
control are free with insurance or
medicaid otherwise prices start as low
as seven dollars per month without
insurance which is very cheap compared
to how much your kid will cost for 18
years
and their licensed medical team is just
a text away to give you the best
reproductive health care so skip the
office visit and waiting in line at the
pharmacy and join the club right now
when you go to the pillclub.com big mood
the pill club is offering a 10 donation
to bedsider.org for every big mood
listener who becomes a patient your
donation will help low-income
individuals get access to birth control
through bedsider.org
that's cool i love bedside
uh that's the pillowclub.com big mood to
get your first birth control care
package and donate to help more women in
need of affordable birth control
remember that's thepillclub.combigmood
you must use the link to make a donation
all right so my hair is not even like
the thing that's going on in my life
already yeah
i just gotta tell you that i don't want
to keep cutting your hair but yeah i
just want to just [ __ ] at me a little
bit
it makes me feel loved
she was gone last month
um but no we're actually uh we're house
shopping right now like seriously where
we're like making offers on places so
you've been saying that for a while and
you're like for sure for sure it takes
me a while
to like you were saying like i need to
get used to an idea first before i can
make a big change that's why i can't
just dye my hair
i need to like get used to an idea for a
while before it goes so we were actually
house shopping for this place for two
years before i was like at the point of
like let's go like let's pull the
trigger now
um so yeah we're finally there we've
been shopping for about a year in las
vegas and i had just a lot of emotional
attachment to this place yeah and there
was like i've lived in california all my
life so it's weird to move to a
different state even though vegas feels
like an extension of la
um i just have never thought i would
leave this state but there's so much
opportunity out there and there's so
much that i love and like our best our
best friend couple that used to live
around the corner from us uh we would
like hang out every single weekend they
moved there two years ago and um they
love it and they've been trying to get
us to like move out forever and so we
finally were like okay
we're doing it um everything in in la
that we had attachments to like we used
to shoot this podcast in a studio
that we moved and then um our podcast
used to be shot in a studio and they
shut that studio down so i'm like okay
well everything we do is from home now
we're kind of like detached from
everything we used to have
solidly in l.a steve kind of goes to jk
does go to jk but it's only twice a
month and since half of jk is already in
las vegas maybe they'll move over there
anyway they might because even um i
think like joe is even staying out there
too so
yeah so
we'll see what happens with that but
we're okay with traveling for work um
the houses we're looking at are just so
worth it
the ones we're looking at right now are
like next to a lake and they're just
gorgeous it looks like california
because when you think vegas you think
like a certain
type but yeah desert and bracelet no
trees but the houses are really nice at
least in this area that we've been
looking and
um every neighborhood has to give like a
little bit of an hoa but the hoas are
really small like here our hoa is 350.
and that's actually on the cheaper side
in the valley
and there it's like 80 bucks and all of
the streets are just completely
landscaped they're like really nice
everything's freshly paved here i'm like
where are our taxes going the roads are
disgusting everything is everywhere yeah
and then also like just like the actual
policies that are like governmental
things where it's like well kind of
california kind of takes it a little too
far yeah like you know that guy that
built a bunch of tiny houses for all the
homeless population and then they they
tore them down the city just destroyed
them because they're like oh it's a fire
hazard
but now they're all living in tents on
the streets like that's not a fire
hazard it's bananas public health
housing cool so let me buy this house
buy my house they want to buy your house
and then we don't want to change sets
yeah exactly
oh my god i have people renting out like
why are you just filming here yes
part of the policy you get one bedroom i
get the rest of the house yeah
bedroom way in the back yeah and then
they don't even you'll even see them
exactly because the way our house layout
is if you watch the vlog you'll probably
see it but it's connected to the other
half of the house just through the
kitchen so everything back there was
super private at one point we were
considering like maybe renting it out
but
you know now we're just going but yeah
i'm really excited because this is the
closest we've been to moving and
i don't decorate
because i know like i don't know if it's
permanent or not well faster like five
years that's true more i can't do it
i am really impacted by my environment
so if i wake up and i hate everything
around me i just don't even want to go
to bed yeah but if i love it i'm like so
ready to work yeah that's why as soon as
we move and like i've moved so many
times in my entire life but i learned
about myself that as soon as i move i
need to unpack everything i cannot live
with boxes and [ __ ] like everywhere like
it [ __ ] drives me crazy i need to
make sure everything's like lived in
already yeah when when we move you won't
hear from me for like two weeks because
i just have to make sure everything is
in place it has to feel like home yeah
it does and even when i first moved out
of my parents house that was the number
one thing i was scared of was like it
won't feel like home because i don't
know
where everything is there's not like
bath towels all ready to go so i fully
bought everything to make it like
exactly how it was at home
to not feel like
what am i doing on my own yeah
but it's cool if i wasn't impacted by my
environment it would definitely save a
lot of money not decorating yeah i'm
like big chilling i have like no artwork
yeah i've seen yeah well your priorities
is like your setup like your my
streaming setup yeah yeah like yeah my
computer's
i mean the green screen makes it look
like your apartment looks amazing yeah
exactly yeah we're just saying my green
screen my green screen your green screen
room oh my god yeah i live there so
wealthy
penthouse
yeah it's a skyline penthouse it's just
like your animal crossing house yeah
yeah yeah oh my god that's right i only
had one nice room yeah that would be my
stream room and then the rest of
everything else just went to [ __ ]
so guess [ __ ] them yeah i guess living
room you get to sit
in your living room because they were
given to you exactly yeah i won them
somehow you wanted a raffle i was like
oh cool this thing's dope do you want
artwork when i leave here sure okay it's
not going to go up okay
sits in a
the thing is it's funny because i
realized that i started hoarding for my
actual place
no you can't do that it's weird you
can't afford random crap you don't
realize your
right now it's in boxes so when i get my
new place it's going to be fantastic
that's the style of house you you're
going to get this is true and that's the
reason why also like it's hard for me to
decorate because i can't decide what i
want when you do move and get like your
house that you're ready to decorate
please call me and tiff so we can do it
why don't you just do it that would be
fun to do together i know that'd be so
fun vampire sheet no see the thing is my
i've gone through like i've seriously
been thinking about redecorating the
last month or so i'm like you know what
i've been here for like five years i
should do something and i've gone
between like
super like streamer beautiful lights
neon and everything or
uh bohemian wood pallets and fake plant
fake plants okay i think do your bedroom
or wherever you're streaming do it like
neon all crazy and then everywhere else
do it bohemian and yeah because you're
you're gonna want a place where you
relax
oh okay which is weird because if i
wanted like it's weird like my computer
neon futuristic everything and then i
don't think in her househouse
for your stream because that's what we
that's why we needed a three bedroom
because we both have offices and then
our bedroom right because i don't want
our bedroom to be cluttered with work
stuff there needs to be a barrier
when you work from home it's like you
want there to be like a separation
between personal and
uh work i should move my desk out to
the dining room
yeah you guys have like those so many
like middle rooms you have like two you
have like three living rooms in your
house you do actually i do but i used to
stream in one of them and but the house
is so old the electricity like whatever
it would power off like
my power would go out because my
computer was just running yeah well
you're sucking all kinds of freaking
amps yeah so i couldn't that's the
reason why i had to move it into my room
because my power cut out like midstream
that sucked hey when i moved to vegas
will you help me set up my streaming
areas because i want to stream poker
games online yeah because i can't do
online poker here but in vegas
oh it could be a twitch poker stream i
don't know can we stream gambling on
twitch i don't think you can in las
vegas you can there's twitch streaming
poker streamers really yeah oh it's just
it must be this or new jersey you just
have to be in the state that allows
online interesting oh yeah it's easy to
set up yeah
sweet are you gonna be selfish like jess
and not let us look through your things
before you move i am not selfish i
actually i told you to come and you were
like i'm so busy there was no there was
a perfect
model again
jessica we're not doing this again not
doing it again you said you ready to go
and you said you didn't want to submit
you told us not to come
we were here i'm still upset no but it's
okay because i would get rid of all
anyway but then tiff could have it yes i
love
but yeah uh i actually had a box of
stuff that i wanted you guys to go
through but then um i had to put it all
away
in storage
yeah just cause if we left our house
soon
you know well i'm ready okay i'm ready
but i will let you know because there's
definitely stuff and there's like stuff
that i'm like i liked this but i just
want to start off sometimes you gotta
just like really let go of even the
things you do like
i know i think we're gonna have to move
once this baby comes because we have
like zero i'll buy your house too
you should you have a bunch of money
saved up yeah you don't spend anything
you're buying property gina that's what
i'm actually focusing on now investing
in
property in property but also sticking
around on stocks and crypto this would
make a great rental property yeah we
were thinking about it but then we
wouldn't have enough for a down payment
in vegas but yeah these like a lot of
them are rented out yeah and three
bedrooms is it's good because like
roommates like you know like 28 year old
roommates or whatever would love a place
like this yeah they're like working
professionally it's very private because
like i can't hear steve he's all the way
back there and i'm all the way up here
and we have to call each other to
be able to talk to each other so it's
very quiet and private yeah it is a good
rental place buy my house i want to
probably buy your house
yeah once the baby comes we're gonna
have to move our entire office into our
bedroom that's like [ __ ] oh no need
to get a new place yeah yeah
hey move to vegas
no i know a place you know the house
next door to the one that we
were making offers on
is also for sale just got listed it's
right next door if you guys become
neighbors that'd be the cutest
babysitters yes
right next door well i mean
maybe no i just i just what about i live
in vegas it's just so hot and cool no it
was okay it was never mind 78 degrees we
went there and it was 88 degrees when i
left l.a so la was 88 vegas was 78 and
there was no smog it was blue skies it
was like i've never seen a sky so blue
and the clouds look like cartoon clouds
because they're like so white compared
to the blue sky but what is it
like
because it's bad yeah oh yeah yeah we're
trying to raise
like really like we use five years
where we used to live to where we
currently live we upgraded in the school
system like now it's like a lot better
it's like you need to move to dallas it
sounds like dude we're actually we
shouldn't be considering it we're kind
of considering even though i complain
about being hot also well dallas is way
north so it's like not anything like
central and south so you don't mind hot
as long as it's humid yeah because
you're sweating out your ass you're fine
with it
you know but you know what humidity is
good for skin and hair so you can age
like jlo j.lo
humidity is great for them
dallas weather is insane do you guys get
like tornadoes earthquakes fires and
like storms and then last winter
one earthquake could wipe out los
angeles yeah cause like las vegas no no
earthquakes i could put a shelf above my
bed
i had a mirror without the [ __ ] wall
anchors i was like nothing gonna take
baby
what natural disaster hits vegas
nothing well drought maybe a drought oh
yeah maybe if the ac went out then maybe
like we'd be [ __ ]
in our houses what about the san andreas
fault it's not like here that way no i
don't think so just down the street down
california
yeah y'all will be an island off of the
u.s if it ever split the land into
hawaii yeah right
jess has been dating she went on a date
in my house she went on a date at my
house pretty round i've only done
facetime screenings yeah but i have so
okay can i start from the beginning a
little bit jesus christ
i got excited tell us about your life
breaking news jess is ready to get laid
not really i mean i don't know i'm on
the fence so i
obviously wasn't dating all of last year
i was really focused on getting my cpa
exams done
and so i just took my last one on
like i don't know like i don't know when
this is coming out but i just took my
last one i haven't gotten the score back
yet but i'm assuming i passed because
you getting all the others yeah because
last time i found out through [ __ ]
stories on instagram yeah and i was like
[ __ ] we're all gonna get junk food i
was like they don't give a [ __ ] so we do
we do but yeah so you're the family this
is my future too if i go broke you have
to take me out i'll take care of you
thank you i will take your you could
battle by the house
but yeah so i finally finished my exams
and i was like okay well that was the
main thing that i had to get done and i
couldn't like get sidetracked because
you know sometimes when you're in like
these kind of shitty one-off
relationships and you're kind of like up
and down and up and down and then it's
like dating is kind of hard and
distracting when you're really trying to
get something important done so i'm
basically done now so i kind of got back
on hinge and i try to get on bumble too
i don't really love that one i don't
know i don't really love online dating
at all but i'm trying it and so i've
done three face time screening dates
like not really dates but just like
let's make sure we are even interested
in going on a date yeah before i waste
my time pre-date pre-approval date yeah
date zero right so send in your papers
yeah your credit score
yeah so two of them um i wasn't really
interested you should actually check
their credit score i mean at this stage
true mm-hmm you know if it comes down to
it i will but we're not you know we got
to get on the first date yeah but
she's actually taking it no i'm trying
to maybe i would i feel like i should be
a newborn i have like a so i'm not going
to get with the 650. listen i'll pay for
half the dinner but show me your credit
score yeah yeah no i'm not paying for
the dinner [ __ ] that anyways um so yes
i've gone on three
face time screening dates haven't been
on any real dates yet the first two i
wasn't interested in and i just had my
third one when i got to nicki's house i
had like we did like an hour phone
facetime
um and i liked him but i told him you
know i'm gonna be out of town this whole
week so
you know text me later there haven't
been any repeat okay like repeat
but i feel like you know there's some
sort of power in
being celibate for over a year because
you have gotten like hotter from being
celebrated i feel like it's a lack of
stress from men
no i haven't done botox in over a year
being celibate is a better
botox yeah the answer is yeah
not letting men stress you out is
actually great that's what's honestly
kind of scaring me because i've gotten
so used to being so stable
and like not dealing with any [ __ ]
not feeling like a hostess person lying
to me like blah blah blah blah so i'm
just like i feel so i don't know like i
don't want anyone to come into my life
now and [ __ ] it up
so i'm just like man maybe i really will
like not
date anyone i don't know like i don't
know if i'm gonna like you're doing it
in a very like efficient way where
you're like screening people because
there's one guy okay so i've been
attracted to two of the three physically
right one the first one i liked him in
photos but when we facetimed i was like
oh no it's not no i'm not attracted but
the other two i've been attracted to
um in the facetime as well the second
one though total fuckboy vibes and i was
so glad that i wasn't there in person
and drinking to like fall into the
fuckboy trap which is something i've
done a thousand times before so i feel
like it's a very
easy way now with the facetime
screenings to be like oh yeah that's
definitely a fuckboy like i'm not i'm
not going down yeah we have to like
leave your house to yeah deal with it
and then you know because i i easily get
sucked in by fuckboy vibes you know like
i will fall for yeah i'll [ __ ] you
know i've done that a million times so
now i'm just like yeah no no no they
always go no no that was a test you
passed the test yeah the thing is though
is if you're not in a rush to have kids
i'm not and you're fine like you're just
you're open but you like your life more
than needing a guy and so if the right
person does come along then cool if they
enhance your life great but you don't
need it which is the best position to be
in exactly you're not desperate it's
weird too because i feel like it's such
a
a novel or like a it's like not a common
way of thinking where you know like we
have guys well that'll be like oh you
need to lower your standards because
you're going to be alone forever and i'm
like that who cares
yeah i'm okay with that she has dogs i
don't know how to tell people like that
don't believe me that i'm like i'm okay
with not being married yes people don't
understand that because i was the same
way before stephen i started dating i
was like
i'm good for being single like for a
long ass time because i just don't want
to deal with i don't like when
my mind is taken up by whether or not
the guy is texting me back or like my
boyfriend might be cheating on me or
some [ __ ] and like i'm dealing with it
it's taking up all of my energy i can't
like focus on work and then being single
was like you know what i actually like
myself i value myself i have my cats
that cuddle with me every night like i
don't i have body warmth yeah you know
no one really experienced like a lot of
people really don't experience that
because i didn't understand that at all
too like but like before i met joe when
i was single during that time in my
early twenties i was just so
sad and desperate and just like oh like
because you're not i needed something i
wasn't okay with myself so like i have
to be with someone and then like the
thought of like dying alone was like the
worst idea ever and then guys would be
like pressuring you like oh yeah well
you should be this and you should be
that that is what a guy's gonna want and
so i would like try to do that and then
that would [ __ ] me over yeah and now i'm
just like
yeah i really don't give a [ __ ] and like
it's sad because i know a lot of people
don't believe me and they're like not
willing to try to get there they haven't
been there and i i totally feel you
because you have to be alone for a
certain amount of time it takes a while
though yeah it takes a while to get over
the hump and then to like also purge
yourself of all this like you have to
unfuck your brain from its wiring that
it was in and then you're like you know
what i actually like myself i like my
own company
yeah yeah so now guys are not competing
against each other for my attention
they're competing against me
in my life and most of them 99
won't
cut it and that's not saying that
they're
not good-looking enough or don't make
enough money or whatever yeah it's just
literally like just like do you enhance
my life or not would my life feel better
with you in it yeah or would i feel more
stressed out and most people are going
to stress you out more than they're
going to make it yeah so the standard
thing is stupid you come to realize like
what's sadder the fact that me not
having kids or a husband or you
not being okay with
having to have someone else yeah are you
like why what's wrong with you depending
on yes what's that like
there's multiple ways to live your life
right and some people are like super
drawn to having a family and i'm like i
think that you're meant to live that
life right yeah like but then i've no i
don't feel like i'm like i have the gene
or something like the thought of having
a child in my body i feel like no
[ __ ] way i feel like i have a high
propensity of having severe postpartum
like i just don't think that i am that
person so like i'm i don't know maybe it
blows some people's mind but i'm just
like i don't think that i'm going down
that road it makes sense because other
people have different like yeah goals
that yeah goals or even like preferences
or like everyone has their own like
route yeah like for example my cousin
she always is like that's what i want
and she doesn't stop until she gets it
yeah she's like i'm gonna be a lawyer
she immediately became a lawyer and then
she was like i want a baby she's like i
don't even care about a husband like i
just want a baby she's like i'm gonna go
i have to move away for this job i'm
gonna find a guy to pregnant me and she
brought back a boyfriend they got
married right away and then she had a
baby right away and she was like i'm
gonna have a baby in two years like she
can make her [ __ ] and she's i like i
don't know she says she's in she loves
her boyfriend or she loves her husband
but like it wasn't this whole like big
love story it was like she wanted to be
a mom she now has a family and she's a
mom and so like you know people have
different ideas of what they considered
to be success and for you and me maybe
marriage and family wasn't like the our
idea of success for me it was always
career based and then i you know
priorities shift as you get older but
yeah i wasn't like i need a man to make
me my life right i haven't gotten to
that point either it's like i don't want
kids and i don't feel like i need a
family i'm just so
happily in love with my work right now
and i just want to focus on that because
this is like a whole new big thing like
i want to do that yeah it's so exciting
yeah
one thing that might help you jess is
putting on deodorant
you're lucky these were remotes yeah
because if it was in person
you know you're not trying to impress
the man but like maybe just
i love the cucumber melon one i like
they're they bring joy to myself native
is our sponsor uh that the best
deodorant because uh native cares about
products you put on your body they love
stopping the stink the right way that's
the native difference it's an organic
deodorant so you don't have to worry
about
aluminium clogging your pores
you probably already know about natives
legendary uh deodorant aluminum-free
deodorant but have you tried their body
wash
toothpaste or their brand new mineral
based sunscreen sunscreen yeah
it's great
it smells really good yeah they have a
broad spectrum spf 30 sunscreen for your
face and body it's lightweight absorbs
quickly and you can choose between
unscented or coconut and pineapple that
one smells good yeah that one's really
good
uh overhaul your entire hygiene routine
by putting the care and self-care with
products carefully made to work against
odor that are made with simple
ingredients and smell great you can get
deodorant body wash and amazing scents
like coconut and vanilla citrus and
herbal musk lavender and rose and more
and you can even build your own
personalized product bundles which is
really cool you can mix and match three
of your favorite scents and keep them on
rotation so you have something for every
occasion
stay fresh stay clean with native by
going to nativedio.com
big mood girls or use promo code big
mood girls at checkout and get 20 off
your first order that's native deo.com
big mood girls or use promo code big
mood girls at checkout for 20 off your
first order
yes
yes yes
if you need some uh
straight white teeth like i have
still indeed
a straight white man
we don't give a [ __ ] about straight or
white but we do and with teeth we do
care about candid clear aligners
thousands of people have you scanned it
the clear comfortable removable and
practically invisible liners to help
straighten your teeth it's pretty cool
how uh you don't have to go to the
dentist you don't have to sit there with
all the anxiety that comes from being in
a dentist's office
you know yeah screaming kids hear the
drills oh yeah that's me i'm screaming
you can just get these comfortable clear
liners from your own home which is great
your treatment is prescribed and closely
monitored remotely by the same life
licensed orthodontist from start to
finish while other companies use general
dentists which who knows how good they
are at this candid only works with
orthodontists who are experts in tooth
movement you can book an appointment at
a candid studio near you or do
everything from the comfort and
convenience of your own home the average
candid treatment is just six months but
you'll start seeing results way before
then and it costs thousands less than
traditional braces with your liner
treatment you'll also get candids teeth
whitening for free
we like it we do love cliff free stuff
candid can help you get the straighter
brighter smile you've always wanted
right now you can save a 75 on candid
starter kit go to candidco.com
mood and use code mood that's
candidco.com
mood with the code mood take advantage
of this limited time offer to save 75 on
your starter kit candidco.com
mood and use the code mood
but also so dating is like really kind
of like last on my list of importance i
also just got a job i know
congratulations
i was like spending so much time
preparing for interviews like i was
watching thousands of youtube videos i
like prepared a ton of um possible
scenarios for questions i could be asked
and then i just like got into the
interview and none of that was even
necessary and i just like got the job
immediately you're definitely an
over-prepared
yeah it's better to be that than to be
yeah so there was a point where like i
got i got a phone interview with a very
very very huge company i was like how
did this even happen like this is like a
statistical anomaly that i even got
selected for even a phone screening
really so i think my resume was just
like really well done online because
everything's like algorithm right so
like whatever i did on my resume [ __ ]
works because i got a phone call from
like the number one company but i didn't
make it through the phone screening
because i think i mean i think after
they kind of look at it they're like oh
you've been out of the industry for like
six years this is probably not the best
candidate compared to like other people
but i was proud of myself that i [ __ ]
made it through the hour
but then yeah so i got um i did i don't
necessarily know if i regret that though
because like some stuff i've been
reading in forums about these like major
major top firms like a lot of the people
that work there are actually really
unhappy right now
so the company that i did get a job at i
feel like is it going to be a really
good medium because it's still like a
very big company i'll still get resume
clout but they're not quite as having as
much
human resources issues as some of the
larger companies so i feel like it's i
kind of got like what's good for me
right now yeah for sure what's meant for
you yeah when like what i can handle at
the moment i'm a strong believer in that
too yeah that you're just like you got
the one that's meant for you yeah i
think so and like because the the
partner that did the interview with me
because i did a phone screening and then
i got to move on to like a partner and a
senior director to actually talk to me
for the interview and like the partner
showed up uh it's all it was all virtual
he showed up with this long a freaking
beard
like santa claus like i don't know
motorcycle guy beard and a t-shirt and i
was like
what the hell you know like just super
character now an accountant for hell's
angels yeah welcome to the team but this
is like a huge international company so
it was like shocking right that's dope i
wouldn't way rather work for that
company so i was just like i think
that's why it was so easy for me to get
that job because i'm you know i'm
a very
talkative easy going kind of casual
person so that
the fact that he showed up as a partner
of this firm with a beard and a t-shirt
it was just so much easier for me to
deal with that than like probably
jumping straight into like the
top level corporate hardcore [ __ ] you
know i just i don't know if i would
if i would have been able to get past
that but so when do you start like
what's the problem like what's happening
um like mid-october oh wow so probably
the time this comes up yeah yeah i
thought you were starting like in a
month or so um well because i was gonna
start like november or something but i
was just like what why even yeah that's
awesome just go ahead and get started so
they're yeah they're shipping my laptop
out to me i think i'm working remotely
still congrats that's even better
well i don't really want to move to
vegas
i honestly don't really want to work
remotely but i'm doing it because that's
just like how the industry is right now
but as an auditor i actually liked going
to different offices and like
being able to travel around and see
different stuff and i like being around
people and i like working in groups and
so like the fact that i just still have
to be at home by myself and my laptop
but honestly because it makes it sound
so long yeah and you were looking
forward to buying business clothes yeah
i wanted to like get cute and like just
by the top they won't see that
there's one mullet outfits dude no i
don't like zoom calls and [ __ ] like that
so i just want to go back in the office
and work so i mean i'm like i'm
vaccinated like as soon as y'all let us
back out in the field like i'm ready to
go but you know i'll just do what i have
to do while i stay home we're still
opposite i know the same keep me at home
i'm like this this podcast is now shot
at my home and i'm still late to it yeah
okay
uh well gina your your show's coming out
soon okay how's that how are you feeling
um kind of nervous but i'm really
excited we are projected to go live
on
when does this come out all right so
we're projected to go out live on tv or
not live i'm sorry we're going to be on
tv
i can't say when so i'm really excited
about it we're the end of this year
ish
we don't know you can't even say that
okay yeah um but i think by the time
this episode comes out we'll be
announcing that we will have our own tv
channel and we're
moving into the studio this next coming
week we built like a 65 000 square foot
studio wow which i don't know how big it
is because i don't know how to compare
that 65 square feet is huge is that like
a costco dude yeah like you know i need
i feel like the costco is like 100 000
square feet
i don't know footage either yeah that's
great yeah okay so we have i just know
how much square footage is my house and
that's it yeah so and that's like 16.
yeah but that's like so your bottom is
eight house times 65
damn yeah it's pretty big
yeah
so we built a new studio it's huge it's
here in burbank and we're moving in next
week and it's kind of crazy like i this
is a huge shift in life and it's weird
they told us we're gonna be
in front
of a very large audience oh [ __ ] it's
live not live oh we're going to like how
many videos it's in a live studio
audience
like a live broadcasted audience
it's not it's it's it's not live live
yeah
right 100 yards that's pretty big yeah
pretty big yeah okay yeah so
but we are confirmed we're going to be
on tv and it's like weird and crazy and
it's scary because i'm going to be on
the show that i dreamed of being yeah
yeah that's amazing but i'm
also having that imposter syndrome you
know it's like oh [ __ ] don't i went from
just you're so perfect for that she
served it girl yeah you worked for it i
don't think all those executives and all
the people that like finally went
through all of the casting would make
mistake like they really don't ever make
mistakes like they know what they want
they know what's going to work yeah
they're not dumb but i get i get why
you're saying that it's a huge step yeah
it's just like her like with the i'm
sure she wouldn't i'm sure he just went
through imposter syndrome with like a
top company calling her yeah yeah so
it's it's a because it feels weird from
going from like this [ __ ] lord on my
computer in my room for less however
many years streaming to
hey like you have a schedule you come in
you film like four or five days a week
we have key cards for you to go into the
facilities we have lunch and
whatever it's like oh i'm like a
straight up corbett person now yeah and
that's weird that's so weird that you're
the one yeah yeah it's so strange like
sometimes we'll text jita and she's
awake at like eight in the morning and
i'm like what the [ __ ] she takes back so
fast she says she has a job now it's so
weird i know now she's getting to places
on time and [ __ ] yeah what this [ __ ]
weird
it's like everything i don't even know
you the opposite of
my whole life fighting against it yeah
um so this month of october where we've
gone dark we to before we did a thing
called before g4 tv which is uh we're
doing we were streaming live every week
um for however many months now they want
to say like since march may or something
and so we've been just streaming on on
twitch and stuff but for the month of
march we announced we're going dark
we're not streaming october october
sorry for the month of october we're
going dark there's no streaming there's
nothing that we're going to be putting
out media wise because we're preparing
for the big thing
and
it's wild man like
huge steps i don't know how i'm going to
take this like i'm going to be famous
i'm going to get my roots ready so i
knew you back
whatever you do please get the right
i'm like [ __ ] that means like i went to
the gym and started going to the gym
because i have to keep up now you
actually have to look hot yeah and it's
really sucks yeah gina this place is
close to work
this is very close to work
you just really want
and like i'm like contemplating going
messy brunette because roots are a [ __ ]
to touch up all the time and they're
expensive and i'm just like trying to
kind of like messed up like when they're
filming too like for the continuity like
you yeah back into a shot your roots are
like four inches long
and like my hair stylist is like booked
out a month in advance all the time so
yeah
yeah it's a lot dude at least you get it
you're a makeup artist on set uh i don't
know if we do wait because for for for
gaming stuff i don't know if we need
that because like we're just a bunch of
nerds you know so it's it's it's a big
shift in life and i am thankful for it
i'm just scared
um but other than that like i'm finally
starting to
invest my money that's why i want to buy
this house and i want to buy a bunch of
investment properties and do stuff
because
we were just talking yesterday because i
was hesitant to put the software on a
place and she's but it has everything
that we want like it's everything that
we've ever that i've ever won this place
here yeah but the place that we're
putting an offer on and she's like why
are you so hesitant i was like i don't
know because i feel like it's such a big
step and i'm like i why like am i
allowed to do like to buy like a double
the house that we have now and it's like
such a great neighborhood i'm like
am i a real adult like that's crazy like
they're trusting like like i'm a child
yeah exactly
dude like i realized that because my
best friend amy she came across this
girl at her workplace she's like 17
years old and she's in the foster system
and amy loved her so much she was like
i'm putting in papers to possibly adopt
her a beer
wow and amy is like a couple years
younger than me and then i had a moment
we're like oh [ __ ] we're allowed to do
that that's amazing
yeah
holy crap this human
i can say and do like things like to
raise this human yeah yeah
i'm like yeah even now exactly when i
tell them to do things i'm like holy
[ __ ] you have to listen to me yeah yeah
it's weird i'm like that with my cat
like who trusted me with a living thing
you know but like i'm starting to
realize oh [ __ ] like we're straight up
we are adults yeah and it's it's still
as confusing as
like we thought they had the shifter
yeah
pretending they have to out people
that's like doing your loan or whatever
like they're [ __ ] idiots too yeah
yeah we're all just a bunch of grown
asses
and then i'm looking back and i'm like
my mom had me at 22 and i'm just not
realizing through conversations how like
they didn't know what the [ __ ] they were
doing i'm like oh [ __ ] yeah adults like
like truly if you're in your young 20s
right now or younger than that like we
don't know like no one knows we're not
gonna go no one knows no one's serious
not even like the president like yeah
exactly
no one knows
like i don't know how to buy houses what
i do is i just hire someone to do it for
me so i'm probably just going to hire
someone even that person is like oh yeah
i kind of know that
and how and how like prices go up and
down like nobody really knows what ever
anything's valued at they just kind of
sped out a number like uh in 750 yeah
sure
they take that because this is a really
sought after neighborhood
okay so
dude i know even like bosses and like
owners of companies and stuff i'm like
oh my god you're really dumb i didn't
know that
i really looked up to like a lot of
people and i'm like holy [ __ ] because no
one knows that you're fooled by the
title two things two things i've learned
growing up is one nobody knows what
they're doing and two more people do
cocaine than you think
yeah really yeah lsd too yeah but a lot
of people you're in los angeles so
that's true that's true i mean like you
yeah so you should probably go to
doctors again by the way like
or get surgeries done yourself because i
mean i've met some professionals yeah
like jesus christ they're like yeah we
microdose whatever yeah exactly some of
the most important professions are
actually like really [ __ ] up
individuals yeah and we just let them
run our country right yeah we're all
confused it's it's it's that's what
growing up is
yeah knowing that no one knows yeah i
still don't know how to do my taxes i
just pay someone to do it exactly like
some of you people just do it on the
computer well you're [ __ ] out of your
mind yeah whatever you don't know how to
do just pay someone to do it well you
can't pay someone to parent your kid so
you're just kind of you can't breathe
uh not really all those rich women whose
kids always speak spanish because
they're nanny's racist i mean yeah you
can but not if you're trying to be the
parent you can't hire someone to be
about that
time out you can i mean that's a good
point but like i don't know like yeah i
always feel [ __ ] lost too i'm like
[ __ ] if i do this it could [ __ ] them up
this way and if i do this it could [ __ ]
them up that way what the [ __ ] they're
gonna do they're gonna get [ __ ] up no
matter what so just have a savings set
aside for therapy for them for when
they're older more than one
therapy phone yeah yeah the college one
you can actually set up a i forget what
it's called but the type of account
where it's like an hsa but for education
so it can like you can invest in stocks
with it and yeah we have one of those
yeah what it's called because i don't
[ __ ] forget what it's called
i should know this but i'm not going to
be in tax so don't ask me any [ __ ]
tax questions okay even though i'm going
to be a cpa yeah she just studied it
yeah don't [ __ ] ask me tax questions
wait now i'm confused you just went to
school for cpa what does that mean so
cpas are not just tax people that's like
saying a doctor they can't that's like
saying a doctor just does foot surgeries
okay okay like there's any other [ __ ]
going on a cpa is not just a tax person
you don't even need a cpa license to be
a tax preparer that's like such a basic
low-level
version of something that but if you can
be a cpa and then like have your own
business
doing just that but what is cpa stand
for again certified public accountant
computer porn analyst
and we're done thank you so much for
listening uh be sure to subscribe check
out our sponsors use our codes tell them
you love us tell them you found us them
through us and uh it helps us out a lot
and also
like us yeah so he's just like in
general just just like comments you
don't even need the thumbs up just like
that like if there's a hairstylist
watching right now in the ellie area
please let me know yeah because i'm
gonna need this done soon things are
getting crazy okay
well you probably haven't done by now
yeah give us give us
whatever how the highest stars possible
like us follow all of our socials and
buy stuff from our
subscribers i mean up from our sponsors
in the description box
until then thank you guys we love you
bye